this surely is a good business to be in
this summer the climate correct
the customers keen
but good sales numbers alone are no
longer enough to prosper inflation has
made sure of that
this is our factories where all the
secret stuff happens this business keeps
its own cows produces its own milk and
manufactures the product on site its
input costs are multiple and mounting
cost of inputs on the farm
cost of diesel cost of fertilizer cost
of winter feeds it's mostly electric so
we've uh you have to keep ice cream cold
right so it's mostly freezer costs and
that's kind of gone through the roof and
don't really know where it's going to
stop i think best cases it stabilizes at
least you know what you're working with
um if you know if you can measure it you
can kind of manage it whereas if you
don't know it's just the fear of it's
just going to go on and on
inflation is now in double digits the
highest in 40 years and the key driver
this time the cost of food
things are so bad the supermarket
iceland has started offering
interest-free micro loans to help people
afford just the bare essentials
the boss says things are set to get
worse
it's going to be an interesting six
months ahead compounded by the fact we
have a drought which is going to affect
future crop yields the war in ukraine is
not helping because it's the bread
basket of europe so
there is a maelstrom of different
pressures i think it's important for
every business to um to accept the fact
they're going to have to have lower
profits to help society to to get
through this
while it appears the price of some
commodities have peaked energy has not
and that's the fear
the fact that food costs the price of
really everyday staples have risen as
much as they have is a sign of just how
unavoidable this crisis has become and
the really scary thing is that we might
end up looking back at this moment as
something of a calm before the storm
energy bills are set to skyrocket this
autumn a recession is forecast it has
the makings of a really serious economic
crisis
all eyes then on what the government
will do a visit to a holiday camp some
say all show and no substance but the
chancellor insists more help is coming
we prepare
all the options ready for the incoming
prime minister on the 5th september to
hit the ground running of what more we
can do whether it is the green levees
that we need to remove to help with
those energy bills cutting taxes
but here they say it may not be enough
food banks should be the safety net but
prices and paranoia have hit even their
ability to help
here you can see fish here you can see
meat that looks a lot
normally
would be out here and about this high oh
really so significantly less
based on the last few weeks because
we've had to buy food in wow so really a
lot less than what you would normally
have
showing that it's hitting everyone right
inflation could peak above 13
they're bracing here they know they'll
be busy
helen and smith sky news